good evening everyone thanks so much for
coming
my name is Candace I work with the
events here at the store on behalf of
the owners in the rest of staff I want
to welcome you if you could take a
moment to silence your cell phones so we
don't have any interruptions that would
be great
we are recording this event we have
c-span here we're also doing our own
recording that will go on YouTube in
about a week we're going to have about
an hour-long presentation here half that
time given to our author's presentation
the other half give in to your questions
we have one microphone over here for
questions if you could make your way to
that microphone we'll be able to catch
it on our recording and everyone will be
able to cure you
at the end we'll have a signing right up
here at this table next to me before you
get in the signing line if you wouldn't
mind holding up your chairs so that
everyone can move around easier that
would be great I'm so pleased to be
welcoming David Cay Johnston to politics
and prose this evening to present his
latest book the making of Donald Trump
no matter what side of the political
spectrum you land on I think we can all
agree that Trump's rapid rise to
political stature is shocking this new
book sheds light on many of Trump's
beliefs which still evade both those of
those of us who are repulsed by him and
those who have relinquished their moral
values to support
Oh fair and balanced areas are the
reflection of my own beliefs and not
necessarily stories um David Kay Johnson
is a Pulitzer Prize winning journalist
whose work has appeared in many media
outlets his four decades long career of
award-winning investigative journalism
has appeared in the Detroit Free Press
of the Los Angeles Times The
Philadelphia Inquirer in the New York
Times his journalism is as mate has had
major influence on the topics he has
covered from exposing political spying
and brutality in the Los Angeles Police
Department to changing American
government policy and freeing an
innocent man wrongly accused of a
vicious murder he writes a weekly column
for The Daily Beast calm as well as a
frequent opinion pieces for the USA
Today The New York Daily News early news
national memo calm and the Rochester
Democrat and chronicle he's also a
consultant on electricity regulation
rare earths
and journalism for the Netflix series
house of cards so please join me in
welcoming David Cay Johnston Republican
well how wonderful to see so many people
here so I want to start off telling you
a little bit about Donald in me and how
this book came about all right because I
don't do politics I do policy so this is
a very strange place for me in 1988 I
left the Los Angeles Times and went to
Atlantic City for the Philadelphia
Inquirer because I believe that casino
gambling was about to explode across
America and become ubiquitous which in
fact it did and almost immediately upon
arriving I met the most important person
in Atlantic City Donald Trump and it
became almost instantly obvious to me
that he was our PT Barnum selling you
tickets to the Fiji mermaid and other
things like this shortly after that I
began talking with his competitors with
Steve Wynn a serious successful gambling
mogul with some gamblers with
government officials and with Donald's
own people and they all told me humble
is running about the casino business and
I'm like that's you how can that be I
mean it's not possible he doesn't know
anything about the casino business so
the first time Donald I sat down and
have a cup of coffee I deliberately said
something to him false and it had to do
with craps and of all the documents I've
saved on Donald at one point before
digitisation became possible I was
renting two storage lockers just to keep
my files on Barron Hilton Jack Welch the
LAPD Daryl gates but mostly files on
Donald I can't find that notebook but
anyway I asked him a question about
craps in which I put in a false
statement and Donald immediately
embraced this falsehood and put it into
his answer now this is what the psychics
you see advertised on daytime TV do this
is what con artists do so in case he had
done that I had prepared several other
questions like that where I dropped
things into the conversation that were
false and every time he immediately
embraced the falsehood and put it into
his answer and that's when I realized
this guy's a con artist whatever's going
on here he is fundamentally at heart
running a scam now I chronicle Donald's
behavior back then I was the person who
broke the story that he was not a
billionaire and when the official
government proceedings established this
a few months later in 1990 we ran in the
Philadelphia Inquirer on the top front
page above the masthead they story with
the lead that began you are probably
worth more than Donald Trump
he had a negative net worth of about 295
million dollars so I have followed
Donald ever since four years ago when
Donald announced that he was running he
was treated quite seriously by my peers
lawrence O'Donnell eyes separately came
to the same conclusion he was really
running for a new contract with NBC for
his television show this time when he
announced I was the only national
journalist who said right out of the box
he's serious this time and I said he
might wasn't likely but he might get the
nomination and the difference was that
his show was very long in the tooth if
you're Donald Trump the worst thing you
can imagine happening short of your own
death would be for the Daily News and
the New York Post to come out with
covers that both say NBC to Trump you're
fired
secondly Donald saw this field that had
no real obvious leader and the one guy
who might have been considered
presumptive Jeb Bush would be pretty
easy to pick off and Donald also if he
ran would be establishing that he had a
bigger audience than he had for his show
Celebrity Apprentice and he'd get a
bigger contract I then was appalled at
the news coverage by my peers now I
watched live when Donald came down with
his wife Melania in front of him to make
his announcement and he went into this
racist xenophobic rant against Mexicans
and Muslims and others and all these
young people are applauding I'm sorry
Midtown Manhattan is not Philadelphia
Mississippi where Ronald Reagan launched
his campaign for the White House and I
thought well okay so he bused in some
people from somewhere well no The
Hollywood Reporter the next day or two
broke the story that in fact they were
actors paid 50 bucks each to show up
and in understanding Donald Trump and
understanding that he is essentially a
fraud that if you like Donald Trump it's
because you like what he sold you not
who and what he is so I called it my
literary agent I said we got to go to a
book and she called around said nobody
believes he's going to get the
nomination it's not going to happen by
the time publishers got around to
deciding there was a book here for
traditional publishers who take a long
time it just wasn't going to happen and
in the meantime I wrote about two dozen
pieces about Donald in a whole set of
different forms Politico USA Today
national memo and the Newsweek and some
other places and then Melville House
called and their specialty is doing
books in a hurry and I had done one book
before in a hurry and they said can you
do this book in three weeks and I said
no but I'll do it in four and I did I
wrote this book in 27 days and I was
able to do that because having done the
lead rewrite for big front-page stories
in the New York Times and the LA Times I
knew how to assemble and do a project
like this in a hurry and those of you
read the book know that unlike my other
books aren't a lot of literary values
and it's mostly back back back back back
back back back back fact with 44 pages
of notes at the end so having laid out
this introduction to you I want to tell
you a couple of key things about Donald
and a couple of key stories about him
Donald Trump is all about money and you
every one of you sitting in this room
you either recognize his greatness and
bask in it and glory in it or Donald has
a word for you loser
Donald is a man who's publicly
humiliated the mother of his children
who you'll read in my book made-up
stories that beautiful women Kim
Basinger Madonna Carla Bruni were
pounding on his bedroom door because
after all everyone in America has got to
have done by the way not only the none
of these women want to notch their
lipstick case two of them had never met
him apparently and the third one had a
brief conversation with him and refers
to him as the king of sleaze now Donald
has spent his entire life doing business
with con artists with mafia with Russian
mobsters with swindlers his entire life
not surprisingly since his father Fred
Trump a very industrious guy who also
was a profiteer on post World War two
housing projects had a business partner
Willy Tomasello who according to law
enforcement reports and the New York
State organized crime task force was an
associate and a front for the Gambino
and Genovese he organized crime families
so Donald not unsurprisingly after
graduating from college where you know
he keeps saying nobody's ever seen
President Obama when he went to Colombia
like you know the women who've been
interviewed about the dates they went on
with him and the people who play
basketball with him none of those people
apparently existed Donald he was partly
anybody saw him at Penn although I did
interview Candice Bergen who told me
that they did go on a date which as she
put it ended early
but when Donnell got to New York he made
a beeline to the notorious Roy Cohn
Senator Joe McCarthy's attack dog and
that relationship helped him he regarded
Roy Cohn as a second father and as a
mentor and he said in writing that he
loved Roy Cohn because Roy would
brutalize for you
Roy would brutalize me so that leads me
to this story I want to tell you about
what happened when Donald's father Fred
died Fred was a really industrious guy I
mean he little business at the age of 15
so did I and when he died two days or
three days after his funeral a new great
grandchild was born a descendant in the
line of Freddy Trump jr. who had died
early he was an alcoholic and did not
have a happy life
and this child immediately became ill
desperately ill stop breathing twice
needed terrifically expensive medical
care now like many family-owned
businesses the Trump's provide everyone
in the family with health care and
Donald is a big believer it's one of the
best things about Donald in universal
health care
well Robert Trump wrote a letter to the
company's insurance administrator
precise and said whatever the bills are
just paying don't ask questions just pay
the bills take care of this job and then
Fred Trump's will was read and it turned
out that instead of dividing his pie
five ways it was divided for the line of
the late Freddy Trump jr. was cut out of
the will except for some minor gifts
surprise surprise
that line of the family went to court
arguing undue influence that although
Fred Trump had been diagnosed with
Alzheimer's about a year and a half or
two years after he wrote his last will
they argued that some influence had been
applied on him to cut them out of the
will the reaction to this by Donald
Trump was that he immediately cut off
all health care
for this child I want to think about
this Donald Trump over money put the
life of a sickly infant in jeopardy his
own blood over money and when he was
asked about this he said well what else
can I do
well don't you think this would look
cold-hearted and Donald's answer is
essentially well you know I don't like
people who sue my father's estate no
compassion for the child anymore there
was no compassion for the con family
whose son is a serving American military
officer killed in combat no empathy for
another person because other people to
Donald are simply objects to be used now
I want to contrast what happened with
this sickly child a judge ordered that
the healthcare continue there was some
kind of negotiated settlement and as
Donald does with negotiated settlements
all the time and by the way contrary to
his statement he never settles he
settles all the time the condition of
settling was they had to seal the record
so we don't know exactly what was done
for this truck well Donald was
confronted with the issue of mercy a few
years earlier so as I tell you this keep
in mind that Donald had no mercy for his
own grand nephew Donald had a famous
helicopter in the 80s you may have seen
him flying around in it and getting
pictures of a call di Bona say uro super
copter and then he had a fleet of
helicopters to run high rollers down to
Atlantic City and back and he these
copters were provided and managed by a
guy named Joe wexel mom a convicted
felon and associate of mob families
there were lots of companies that had
helicopters there were better finance
companies than this one but this is who
Donald chose it turns out Joe exelon had
a second business he was a major drug
trafficker he ran a drug ring that got
cocaine and marijuana from Colombia they
think
up in Miami according to the court
papers Joe exil mom personally handled
the drugs he sometimes helped load them
into the cars he would give the drivers
money or plane tickets or whatever they
needed to go on and they would go up to
Cincinnati and areas near there he was
indicted in the fall of 1985
now when you own a casino you have a
privilege the Supreme Court and those of
you who read my book temples of chance
know the casinos are not a right they
are a privilege therefore the state can
impose virtually any rule it wants on
you and the state of New Jersey said you
must prove by clear and convincing
evidence that you can pay your bills on
time that you are morally fit and that
you do not associate with criminals well
Donald didn't get rid of joe Exel bombs
helicopter company at this point Joe
LexA mom then agreed to plead guilty the
DEA had him cold and he asked that his
case be moved either to Miami where the
drugs began and he had a home or New
York City where he lived the case
instead was moved to New Jersey which
neither the prosecutors nor the defense
lawyer have ever been able to explain
and it came before out of the more than
800 District Court judges in America
judge Marianne
Trump Barry his sister now judge Barry
is required to recuse herself from this
case and she did about three weeks later
but just think about the conversation
that went on here she goes to the chief
judge and says um you know I can't
handle this case with this big drug
trafficker because my husband is a
lawyer for my brother's casinos he flies
in those helicopters all the time and I
fly in those helicopters and you're the
chief judge saying I got a federal judge
flying around in a drug traffickers
helicopters potential here for real
embarrassing things to happen for the
federal judiciary Donald meanwhile shows
his mercy to this man he writes a letter
pleading for him to get a short sentence
calling him diligent saying basically
he's a stand-up guy you know
should be treated lightly by the courts
when the New Jersey Division of Gaming
Enforcement goes to ask Tom about the
letter he says I know what is talking
about you could construe that as a
cover-up
certainly is lying so they go back and
get the letter that they didn't have
they show him the letter and Donald says
yeah that's my signature end of inquiry
not why are you doing business with this
guy why did you do business with this
guy what other business relationship did
you have with him what's going on here
they did ask a few questions about and
you'll read in the book an apartment
that Joe exilim and his brother rented
under rather unusual circumstances an
apartment in a different building than
Trump Tower but that was owned
personally by Donald Trump
well Joey wexel bond comes up for
sentencing before the new judge he gets
a very light sentence and 18 months
after he walks into prison he walks out
he also says he has no money he can't
pay his fines by the way the the people
who drove the drugs the little fish 20
years up to 20 years so Donald flutter
seeking mercy work this big drug guy he
got a light sentence now think about
that not only in the context of his not
showing mercy but brother brutality
toward this sickly child who's helpless
but in terms of all of Donald's attacks
about murders and rapists and drugs and
you know in the black communities of
America he basically has said nobody has
a job and everybody has crime and no one
has an education think about those in
the context of that
by the way when Joe at Wexley bomb came
out he said he didn't have money to pay
the fines of he oh that were imposed by
the court but he did move into a 2.4
million dollar apartment in Trump Tower
now all throughout his career Donald
Trump has been the subject of lawsuits
he cheated employees he's cheated
vendors he has been accused of swindling
investors in projects that his name was
on he settled many of these cases and
had them sealed so we don't know exactly
what happened but we have his testimony
in many of these cases and his testimony
is generally one of two categories I had
no idea or well you were lucky if you
invested this that the project failed
when it did you could have put all your
money into the project and you'd have
lost more money that's his approach to
these things Donald when it comes to
these deals also often pleads that he
doesn't know things and you'll see some
answers that he gives to questions
presented to him under oath where his
answers are gibberish I don't know what
else to call them you may have watched
in December the Republican debate and
then that debate Hugh Hewitt very smart
right-wing radio talk-show host and a
lawyer he represents the companies and
environmental deals he's on the protect
the company's interest side and he asked
Donald Trump what's your priority among
the nuclear triad and Donald Trump's
answer which I quote in full was
gibberish I don't know what else to call
it and skew it asked the question a
second time and Donald says Oh nuclear
nuclear that's like it's so massive and
impressive you know it's like it's a big
deal
and Hewlett says senator Rubio same
question well let me first as you tell
the American people what the nuclear
triad is if they don't know it is the
ability of our the United States
military to deliver nuclear weapons from
submarine-based missiles land-based
missiles or bombers when you got to be
schooled by Marco Rubio you don't know
much but here's the thing that what my
wife and I were watching that debate and
I said that should be the lead item in
the coverage of the debate tomorrow by
everybody that this is this most crucial
matter of your finger on the button and
Donald doesn't know anything and I said
however my guess is it'll get minimal
mention well actually a lot of the
stories didn't even mention it they
completely missed it because politics
reporters cover the horse race they
don't cover policy they don't know they
don't know what the nuclear triad is nor
do they know the significance of this
question but here's what turns out
people didn't know that's in my book see
you he lit asked the exact same question
four months earlier on his radio show so
Donald had four months just get schooled
on this and I ran into Hugh here in
Washington a couple of weeks ago never
met him before and I even know about my
book and I told him the story and he
says yeah I said boy yeah four months to
get ready for that didn't mean he didn't
do a thing Donald doesn't know anything
all you have to do is actually step back
and listen to what he says I'm going to
tell the disco and Ford they can't build
a factory in Mexico it's not within the
powers of the president United States to
go around telling corporations where
they're going to spend their money and
where are the principal conservatives on
this issue can you imagine at President
Barack Obama came out and said that
dollar chomp through his companies owes
millions and millions and millions of
dollars to the Communist Chinese bank of
China which is essentially controlled at
the end of the day by the nine thugs who
lead the government in Beijing can you
imagine what would happen if Hillary
Clinton it turned out had a credit card
from the Bank of China
Donald Trump has received millions and
millions of dollars from Russian
oligarchs one of his sons has said oh
yeah they're one of the biggest sources
of money that we have I don't know how
many of you saw but there was a really
terrific well done story in The New York
Times a few days ago about all the
people who are enemies of Putin either
put either oligarchs or journalists who
have been murdered and down in the story
was a civil line that the Duma had
passed a law so that Putin could kill
people outside the country now we've
killed a few Americans outside the
country but they're people who declared
themselves enemies of the state and you
can argue that's right or wrong but look
at what Putin saying and poisoning
people and poisoning innocent people in
some cases having people shot if you're
in all a dark in Russia you're either a
friend of Vladimir Putin or you're in
jail or you're living in fear and trying
to get out of the country Donald Trump
keeps advancing Vladimir Putin's
objective weaken or destroy NATO imagine
what would have happened if we had had
George W Bush saying hey you know we
should just weaken NATO the trouble he
would be in over this the the most
important thing and the reason I wrote
this book is that Donald Trump is a
master at a couple of things he is a
master at setting up business deals in
which he puts up no money he never had a
dollar invested in Atlantic City and
extracting money from these deals
that's why his Atlantic City casino
business was among the first to fail
there are profitable successful casinos
in Atlantic City right now today but
Trump's name will disappear on October
10th from the last casino because he had
badly run places and instead of
investing in the business and growing
the business and doing what and I'm
somebody who has co-founded a little
business
p-nut business but 25 workers we
reinvest in the business so it keeps
growing to create wealth Donald Trump
pull money out as fast as you can pay no
attention to the welfare of the business
just get cash when Donald Trump filed
bankruptcy and stiffed all these
contractors some of whom their
businesses failed many of whom for years
ruggle to keep the doors open because
they felt an obligation to their
employees
Donald demanded big huge fees be paid to
him during the bankruptcy or he would
tie them up in litigation and so they
paid him until in the fourth bankruptcy
they paid him to go away
Donald is the most masterful manipulator
of the conventions of journalism I have
ever seen
Donald understands first of all that
most journalists are very good at
accurately quoting people and accurately
getting other sides of the story and
quoting them but have no deep
understanding of what's going on and he
exploit that he knows that the tabloids
especially Rupert Murdoch's New York
Post have no real regard for any set of
facts they'll take a good story any day
of the week so he plants a story that
his longtime mistress whom I knew about
long before anybody wrote about her but
I didn't regard the story billionaire
has mistress now plane takes off in
Washington lands in LA not a story and
either takes he plants this story there
with a big picture of his smiling face
and the cover the most best sex ever
Marla maples by the way as you'll read
in the book has disclaimed that
statement she didn't make it he creates
this image of himself as this Mitas it's
all from it is a fraud there's nothing
there and I know some of you are going
to want to ask how much is he worth and
I'm going to tell you I don't know but I
know he's not worth as he said in a
matter of days last year eight point
seven billion ten billion more than 10
billion 11 billion what I do know is
what Donald said under oath when he had
to answer questions about how much are
you worth and he said well it depends on
my emotional state
the lawyer goes excuse me the lawyer who
is now the head of enforcement at the
SEC and he asked a little further and
Donald says well yeah I mean it depends
on how I'm feeling that day that's you
know what's happening in the world and
how my mood is that that's how I
determine my net worth now if this guy
was running for president United States
I think we'd all agree
that's crazy that's absolutely crazy
that is that nobody does it that way and
throughout his life Donald has gotten
away with this because almost nobody
challenges in Wayne Barrett probably the
best reporter who ever worked in New
York City who's got on to Donald very
early on and wrote about him at length
in the Village Voice and who despite
working the Village Voice had the most
extraordinary law enforcement sources of
any reporter I've ever known and I and a
guy named Neil Barsky at the Wall Street
Journal until Donald pulled a trick on
him and he got fired we're basically the
only people really examining Donald
everybody else he was a good story
wouldn't leak what you getting to do a
bunch of work for Donald said this thing
and it's a good story and we would say
yeah well let's go look up the records
and we would question what was going on
so before we go to questions I just want
to get across to you that the person you
have seen the image created by Donald
Trump with the complicity of our major
national news organizations who are
utterly failing in their duty with a few
notable exceptions the Washington Post
has tried pretty hard one TV reporter
Katy tur has at least asked the tough
follow-up questions on him by and large
Donald Trump has gotten from the press
what he wants to create this image that
he is the modern mitis that as he said I
alone can save you that's not the
statement of the leader of a free people
in the democracy that's the statement of
a would-be dictator he has said I love
the blacks and you would think most
journalists even white journalists would
have enough sense to say boy that's an
interesting way to phrase that statement
and they might want to go look up the
times that Donald has been found to have
engaged in discrimination against blacks
and women and Asians found who've done
so been fined for it they're not doing
that why is he on all the time why has
he gotten what I buy the last measure I
saw was more than four billion dollars
of free media because he's like a train
wreck
people won't turn away from the TV
foxnews has put out the story that when
they turned off Donald people turn off
their TVs or go to another Channel this
is no way to run a democracy this is
serious business
and unlike Donald Trump who can say in
his TV show something totally contrary
to sound business practice and I say
this is somebody who I teach graduate
business students and law students
part-time you're fired
he can't fire the dictator in North
Korea he can't fire the Speaker of the
House he can't fire a federal judge who
issues an order he doesn't like Donald
Trump tells you he has this sort of
vague plan he's going to build a wall
he's going to get the trillions of
dollars or certainly many hundreds of
billions of dollars needed however he
does it because he's changed slightly
now to round up people in the country
illegally not the people by the way I
described in my book who worked for him
and who's cheated out of their wages but
round them up and other things he's
discussed that he can't do it unless
Congress passes legislation allowing him
to do that and providing the money have
you ever heard of a President United
States picking a fight with the Speaker
of the House and then appointing to run
his campaign a guy like Steve Bannon who
says at Breitbart that Paul Ryan is a
double agent for Hillary Clinton
this is craziness so I want to take
questions from you I hope that you will
read the book it's a quick read because
it's written in new style there are 44
pages of notes at the end so that you
can look up stuff if you don't believe
me my personal email is in the book and
a few people have gotten a hold of me in
taste people have questions about
material comes from and I will just
leave you with this last point when I
was 18 years old the San Jose Mercury
recruited me to be a reporter and they
hired me at 19 and throughout my career
I have broken stories where people told
the editors at the mercury and at the LA
Times and The New York Times that's just
crazy that can't be you know when I said
that the police chief in LA was
assigning officers to sleep with women
to get political information that can't
be that they were committing crimes and
started a riot can't be had officers
undercover in Moscow in Havana
subsequent events that all came out to
be true the police chief in fact himself
bragged in his autobiography the LAPD
had undercover officers in Moscow in
Havana and in 50 years at this where
I've accused people of murder Jack Welch
gave up his retirement perks the head of
Ernst & Young lost his job President
Bush made his only tax policy change the
Clintons changed how they file the
personal tax returns every bit of the
work has held up it's been scrutinized
all over the place and it's held up and
in this book you're going to find stuff
that will hold up and I only wish I'd
had five weeks to do the book because
there's a whole much more I wanted to
put in there thank you
so the microphone is over here and the
only thing that asks you to do is if
you're going to come up to the mic from
ask a question think about what you want
to do and ask the question because a
bunch of people are going to want to ask
questions that I want to do as many as
we can
you make a very persuasive case
completely persuasive why has the
Republican Party allow Trump to be where
he is today
because Donald got the votes I mean it's
as simple as that and but what you're
seeing on a broader scale is parties are
not important anymore
what what's important in citizens united
really hammered this home is it's the
people who are financing the campaign
these very narrow groups of people in
the country who are financing campaigns
parties don't have discipline when the
German TV interviewed me and I've been
well I haven't been on ABC NBC or CBS
I've been on all these national shows in
Australia and Canada and Germany and
France about the book one of the
correspondents said to me you know if a
minor back venture said just a few of
the things Donald said the party would
discipline this person that that didn't
work they would get him out of there
once you have to stand party has no
power here and so that that's what's
happening and I think you're going to
see a major realignment I mean I've said
in the past this may be the end of the
Republican Party as we know it the way
the Whigs went away in 1856 but they're
going to have to have a major
realignment and those Republicans who
have not separated themselves from
nominal Trump Glenn Beck said the same
thing last night on lawrence O'Donnell
that I've been saying I don't know how
you get the stench off after the
election it's like permanent skunk juice
go ahead okay we jerk sir oh ah two
quick questions uh there is a book that
came out Oh
six months ago that was a political
biography I'm sorry a political campaign
biography by Trump and I'm sorry I
forgotten the name okay I've got all
Donald books and I've read the ow you
know what you must have it see it was a
recalled crippled America but he's
retitled it yes I think it's retitled in
any case
no one hand the media have mentioned
that book I'm so [ __ ] I get he
mentioned yeah it actually got a fair
amount of coverage when it came out and
I would always caution you against
saying no one has because if you go look
you'll find somebody yesterday posted at
Twitter that no one had written about
none of the news had written about
Hillary Clinton the State Department and
her email so I went to Google 19 million
eight hundred places it found but I
think it's gotten relatively little
tension like most books do like this
because they're written for the audience
of supporters and they're not serious
tracks okay I mean we've had a few rare
exceptions of Barack Obama's book that
he wrote I think was one of the very few
exceptions to having a serious book so
and the other the other question is can
you predict what the new Trump that
they're trying to invent now yeah how
successful my he be and look like what
are they I am NOT a politics reporter so
I have absolutely no idea about that but
let me be clear when people argue around
Trump you know you're going to see the
new Trump I subtle snippet on TV one day
just by chance where there were a group
of middle-aged women talking about Trump
and may have been the view or a show
like that and and one of them said yeah
well this is like you're these numbers
he's only like forty five it's like you
know your girlfriend says oh I found
this guy and we're going to get married
and after we get married I'm going to
change him any seventy years old
yes sir this may be a little bit too
local given the lot a little bit of time
you had to deal with Washington DC but
supposedly sometime around a 12th of
September Trump International Hotel is
supposed to open in Washington c-hawk
Pennsylvania Avenue now it's been buried
there's been one columnist in The
Washington Post who's got a good bite on
this thing and has pushed it the mayor
apparently in the city and if all the
people had to be involved when they cut
the deal with Trump to build a hotel
before all the lawsuits over the host
over the restaurant all that basically
didn't make a lot of this stuff public
and there were some freedom of
information stuff that was done to get
some of the details out but what it
appeared was the columnist for The Post
indicated that maybe because the things
you'd written and others had known that
he had to have some kind of a guarantee
of about forty five million dollars and
yet to get a loan from I think Deutsche
Bank I cover whatever outage it would be
so then in theory if he walked away from
that deal like he did the other ones
you've written about right the city
wouldn't get hosed they'd actually get
something you believe that's likely to
be the case well I haven't seen the
contract in this case I'm aware of what
she's talking about let me point out
that American banks won't loan money to
zone
Donald himself has said I borrowed money
knowing I didn't have to pay it back and
I've made a lot of money borrowing money
I didn't pay back which is true and so
Deutsche Bank which is been at the heart
of these big illegal tax shelters I was
exposing years ago in the New York Times
right
drinks banks one of the few banks that
were loaning money and generally on
terms that secure them pretty well but
in this project if we had a fine
forensic audit of it internally we'd
find out Donal doesn't have any money in
it I'm sure that because Donnell doesn't
put money into anything all of his deals
are you give me money so all right well
a quick follow up on that was apparently
there were some kind of a guarantee I'm
not quite sure what the term was that he
had guaranteed the city at least forty
five million dollars out of his own
money if he walked away now do you think
that's another joke I I don't think that
if you if we had the contract the
documents I think we'd find out even if
it says Donald
there's something else in there we
haven't seen cos Donna just doesn't do
this like he used to when he went fell
apart in 1990 he owed nine hundred plus
million dollars on essentially a credit
card because all these banks thought
they were the only ones making unsecured
loans to him with a personal guarantee
and they paid badly for their bad
judgment we get any women asking
questions are just a whole group of
people like me old white guys I'm having
as I change on Saturday go ahead got a
question on conflicts of interest the
polling data these days does suggest
that Donald Trump is in a whole and
probably not going to win it I don't
cross the polls this year to be clear I
don't know because I think there are
awful lot of white people in America who
underneath their skin they don't want to
sit next to a black person or a brown
person or a yellow person on an airplane
but go ahead if you were to win the
election what sorts of conflicts of
interest won't see and what are you from
your knowledge about the Trump
University case what where do you see
that going let me deal with Trump
University first there's a whole long
section about Trump University in my
book as a matter of law I don't see how
Donald Trump gets out of the Trump
University mess it is a bait-and-switch
fraud from beginning to end and the
Texas Attorney General's staff who were
denied bringing litigation against
Donald civil litigation they laid out
the defenses he would make and showed
why they wouldn't stand so I don't know
what he's going to do there and there
are three lawsuits to class action suits
and the New York state attorney general
you'll also read about a campaign
finance contribution that the IRS should
have shut down the Donald J Trump
foundation but they've done nothing
because guess what we've stripped the
IRS of assets to do its job and stats
we've done on the first part of the
question about if Donald gets elected
president conflicts of interest are a
minor problem yeah
let me give you the big problem maybe
the big problems we'll have right off
okay Donald called me April 27th at home
to tell me that you know he'll sue me
unless I write what he likes I you know
I'm doing this almost 50 years from the
Santa Cruz California City Council to
the White House he's the only politician
has ever told me that ever and I've
ended the careers of a fair number of
both Democrats and Republicans
if Donald is elected first of all I
absolutely believe that some federal
agency will start causing me trouble
because Donald's going to use the
government to go after the people he
doesn't like because that's how he sees
the world and I talked at length about
his personal philosophy he's written
about a great length which is revenge
the only person I know who says I'm a
Christian whose whole philosophy is
destroy other people secondly I would
mostly be worried if I were a senior
United States military officer and I
will I think we can reasonably assume
that the men and women who are in the
Situation Room have all pulled out their
law books to have a precise
understanding of what happens and how
you refuse an illegal order from the
commander in chief because this is a man
who's talked about well why don't we use
nuclear weapons in in Europe those are
our allies we're going to torture people
we executed Japanese officers during a
fter World War two for waterboarding
people these people are not going to
commit crimes that put them in jeopardy
of their freedom in their lives and that
will be a crisis because Donald will
order them to do these things and if you
see him fire one general or Admiral
that's when you need to really get
worried because of the implication of
where that's going okay sir this
question is in the context only of him
losing the good news about Donald Trump
having run so what's the question if he
loses you agree it was with the
statement it well but if he loses what
what did the election okay
the Republican Party that started being
the racist institution that it was with
a solid majority on the Nixon is I see
it now is totally kaput I'm not sure
which one
what's going to happen Republican Party
if he loses the I do agree the
Republican Party is basically gone as it
has been I don't know if the Republican
Party is gone it may be and I've said
that okay we certainly are going to see
a massive realign but let's not just
beat up on the Republicans on a
registered Republican after all it was
the Democrats in the South you know who
ran Jim Crow right the Republicans have
been trying now for 50 years to create
this image that we are the Conservative
Party and as conservatives we are
principled people and we believe in
markets my books are about in large part
the undermining of market economics and
rent-seeking in favors that we are not
racists and that we are not xenophobes
and you know Donald Trump's completely
undone 50 years of efforts to sell that
message because it's not saleable right
now and I think you're going to see a
huge crisis after the election if he
loses and an effort to figure out what
do we do and where do we go but none of
that will matter unless we stop what's
happened in campaign finance and
citizens united is the worst part of
that Chief Justice John Glover Roberts
is wrong about this
the founders wrote at length about their
concerns that inequality would destroy
America and I've written about this you
can look up my pieces of Newsweek of
elsewhere about it the founders were
worried that money would lead to a
society in which the business
aristocrats would set up rules and
persuade people who were workers only
that if they had no property they didn't
owe them tools they didn't own land and
because they had no property they would
deceive those people into voting for
policies that favor the business
aristocrats and damage their own
interests kind of like what I think
we've seen in the last 35 years so I
think will be a big crisis about it
where it's going to go I don't know the
Democrats need to have a realignment to
though you know they need to stop being
Republican like yeah thank you sir
um why um these facts you brought to
light about the mob and things like that
why doesn't the media go into and white
us and Hillary bring up how he called
sir dishonest and he said something also
I'm wondering if you could talk about
his father's ties I think it was with
the Klan or yes but well first of all I
don't know why Hillary's doing her
campaign the way she does I'm not a
politics person okay I mean I know I'm
sounding like I'm copping out but I
don't like covering politics
I like policy alright but secondly if
you're going to say that Donald Trump is
involved with these mobsters and drug
dealers and others two things happen
I've had a number of TV shows call me
and they say well we need to have
somebody from the other side and I've
said okay and they can't find anybody
and the Trump camp I said well all the
Trump campaigns all I'm going to be on
ask them for a surrogate well they don't
want to participate well I you know if
you're not going to participate that
shouldn't allow you to kill the story
okay and they're all have libel concerns
even though this is in the public record
this is court documents Donald's own
testimony and the reality is that the
news business has shrunken down the
fastest disappearing white-collar job in
America or virtually the fastest in the
last 15 years has been journalists and
news rooms have been shedding people
like crazy I went back to the New York
Times newsroom not so long ago and I it
was two o'clock in the afternoon I
thought preceding Donald Trump's famous
remark I could fire a shotgun off in the
slice and not hit anybody it means a lot
of people there but but it's shrunk and
with that shrinkage there's a lot more
concern about having money diverted from
news to litigation and a view that the
public doesn't want aggressive
journalism and if there's any message by
the way the American people have given
top journalists the top editors and
publishers it's we don't want you doing
what I do we don't want you doing this
because it upsets us it tells us things
that we don't want to know we want to
believe what we believe
oh all right about the Klan all the Klan
thank you I'm sorry
in 1927 about a thousand guys in white
robes and supporters mostly people who
were supporters got into a pitched
battle with New York City police in
Jamaica Queens the newspapers at the
time reported and those days when you
were cotton went to the cop shop you
know they gave you the arrest report
anything else that among the people
arrested was Fred Trump it gave his
address in Queens Donald told the New
York Times and this is in the book
earlier this year well that wasn't my
father it was somebody else he never
lived at that address and there were no
charges so you shouldn't write about
there are no charges you shouldn't write
about it you know you're not supposed to
write about it there were no charges but
I don't think it was him well it was him
it was his address the public records
show it's his address and the idea we
shouldn't write about something unless
there's a criminal charge I don't think
I've seen him apply that to Hillary
Clinton okay so next there so what do we
at least move out of the old white guys
I'm right here I'm not really that way
but I said we build out of it yeah so
why do you think there's a sudden rise
in Medinah shot style politicians not
just you know in democracies
non-democracies everywhere right all the
world England yeah yeah why is it that
all around the world we're seeing
fundamentalist religious leaders Modi in
India who's a fundamentalist Hindu in in
the Muslim world although I would argue
because I actually read the Bick the
magazine of ISIL that they're apostates
they're not Muslims we're all around the
world we're seeing this we're seeing
them on Christians I think it's because
the speed which human knowledge is
changing things people can aren't
equipped to cope with I think that
people are looking for some you know
what's coming and they're uncertain and
world economics are changing and and the
arize of the internet which is
eliminated enormous numbers of jobs in
the world and it's going to eliminate a
lot more jobs in the world by making
things more efficient but you know I
will say inefficiency creates jobs
it's leading people to be a fearful and
the nature of how we do television news
if it leads it bleeds people think
there's a lot more crime out there than
there is you know we have very very low
crying now compared to the 1980s
compared to the 60s compared to the 20s
oh yeah crimes as on the national level
way way way down in this country your
odds of being burglarized today are
roughly one and for what they were in
1980 and most burglaries are done by
adventuring teenagers usually boys but
not always they're not done by serious
burglars and so I think this this rapid
pace of change and the explosion of
television driven news has it has really
created a lot of fear and anxiety among
people and then we do have some
societies mostly our quote unquote
friends in Saudi Arabia who are running
schools where you know children are
taught every day the same thing they're
taught in North Korea hate America yet
today action in New York signs out the
video yeah that's good on it yeah yeah
okay okay what do you think can be done
if anything to get Trump to release his
tax returns that are in issue well and
what do you think
what's the book you'll see basically
what's in Trump's returns I have shown
that Donald almost certainly committed
tax fraud in 1984 his own tax guy
disavowed his tax return Donald has
participated in a sales tax fraud
there's a lot about Dom's this is the
area that I've best known for his taxes
we're never going to see Donald Trump's
tax returns okay but what I've said is
journalists should start saying to Trump
okay
you said you can't release the returns
that are under audit this is nonsense by
the way but we'll take you at your word
we'd like to see your 1978 to 2008 tax
returns because you have said the audits
are closed on those returns and he
should be hounded about that
where are your pre 2009 tax returns and
not as was suggested the other day by
larry gibbs who's the former IRS
commissioner form 10-4
Plus schedule a which has charitable
deductions his complete returns now Ron
MIT Romney wouldn't give us his returns
because I understood how many people
raise your hand if you know this MIT
Romney was not the manager of Bain
Capital Management he was the sole owner
anybody in the room know that okay one
person read my coverage back then he was
the sole owner and Congress has special
rules if you're the manager of a hedge
fund or a private equity fund you can
live tax-free you fold all your
partnership profits back in then the
carried interest they talk about you pay
that and this is the future which means
the government just loaned you at zero
interest all the taxes you should have
paid this is how people to the top are
getting very rich the government keeps
saying oh you can pay your taxes you
know somewhere in the distant years from
now decades from now and it's a zero
interest loan you imagine how rich you
would be if all the income taxes
withheld from your check were in your
investment account and now you had to
pay it back with no interest and we're
never going to see Donald's returns we
need to pass a law I actually wrote a
column in The Daily Beast laying out
hazardous ever a column for Donald about
how to come clean about his taxes that I
actually believe if he had the courage
to give it would get him elected
president it's called the the the speech
that could like Donald Trump president
and then I wrote I've written that
Congress should pass a law that if you
appear on the ballot of more than Pitkin
umber ten states running for president
the IRS is required to disclose your tax
return and the only thing they're going
to hold back your social security number
and your home address if you use the
home address and tax returns republic in
the 20s you know you can find out how
much Julius Rosenwald the founder of
Sears Roebuck whose founder but
certainly they got to build it up paid
in taxes so we're never going to see his
returns but in my book you will read a
lot about his tax returns so we have
time for about oh we got six minutes
flex this is a short one I'm just
curious to know why you're a registered
Republican
they are the party of the big tent I'm a
Teddy Roosevelt guy they should welcome
me and I've had many people Khanderao
saying you're a rhino I say I'm sorry
either you're the party of the big tent
or you're not and where I live in
western New York the primaries are much
more interesting and after all I
actually got to while I didn't get to
vote because the polls that day opened
after I had to leave town but I was
going to vote for a man running for
president few years ago who believes
dinosaurs and human beings coexisted and
you know Democrats don't give you
opportunities like man as someone like
you who wrote about Trump's tax returns
and what could be in them back in March
I've been disappointed every time I
write about these issues that the people
that really need to learn more and
understand them don't use to listen
where did you write about I write for
Market Watch okay so I don't but but let
me ask the question so the question is I
don't want to preach to the choir the
reason why I took a job as a journalist
that's 54 years old is because I want to
convert those who don't believe in what
they should and don't understand yet
where they should of course so the
question is how do we do that how do you
and I do that is it writing a book is it
writing more is it is it going out there
and telling me I'm not in the business
of trying to convert people to what I
think is the right way to think okay in
my class at Syracuse University when
they asked me to teach they thought I
would teach modern tax policy at the end
of the day that just becomes no matter
how hard I try what I think about tax
policy which teaches nobody anything I
want to give people useful information
in a way they can understand it so they
will come to decisions now the point
that you're raising that we have a lot
of people in this country and they're
not going to honor is who will not pay
attention to facts there's actually been
a lot of psychological research done
about if you want to read a good quick
little book Farhad Manjoo f AR H ad MA
and Jo wrote a book called true enough
and when you look at the cover you'll
think it's a boy scout
it's not but it's true enough to being a
Boy Scout now what the research shows is
that if you tell people something they
believe is not true Saddam Hussein
you know a Baptist thug had nothing to
do with a religious zealot by the name
of Osama bin Laden you show them
videotape of President George Bush
saying of course Essam Hussein had
nothing to do with 9/11 their response
will be although they were just trying
to appease the liberal media and you can
find the same things with people on the
left you can show it about football
games he talks about it what he calls a
famous football game I think it was
between Princeton and Harvard I don't
know how famous that would be but
there's lots of research of this where
people double down on what they wish to
be true and I think that's a failure of
our education system we have an
education system that was designed to
prepare people for growth jobs drone
jobs not for critical thinking skills
you can have a better conversation with
the average waiter in rural Slovakia or
Canada then you can with the average MBA
sit in the first class on a jetliner and
it's I think that's a failing of our
education system and we need to really
work at that we need to make people more
politically sophisticated we need to
make them critical thinkers one of the
things I've been fascinated by is that
my children grew up with very good
schools and they know you don't trust
anything on the Internet but I've had
students and I've gone and lectured at
high schools where students say what
Donald Trump said what was on the
internet and they assume it's true and I
think this is a this problem is not
going to get solved in my lifetime and
it's not going to get solved probably in
yours well I'm going to go teach so go
try I'm taking your least try hi there
hi you've told us many bad things about
Donald Trump but are there any positive
things about dollar drama in your book I
can say a couple of positive things
about Donald Trump I mean he'd built
camp Tower which is quite an
accomplishment he successfully shut down
numerous law enforcement and journalism
investigations about himself that's an
accomplishment I mean it
me what most people think is positive
excited just from his perspective that's
a very positive yeah no but but I mean
the fundamental fact is no I've tried
very hard and when you read the book I
think you'll see why Donald is a
world-class narcissist
Donald is only about Donald you don't
exist except to either glory Donald or
be a foil and he just he has no empathy
for other people and so everything he
does is about money cutting off the
health care for this child it's about
money and so you know I what I was
working on the book and I was sleeping
and worrying and sleeping and writing
you know I I called up some other people
I said I got to have some perspective
here you know let's go through some
things Donald has done and nobody could
come up with anything his businesses
fail because he doesn't know how to run
a business he's not a good negotiator
there are people who teach negotiation
who've written about this and terms of
his deals tell you that and no I can't
point to anything beyond the signature
accomplishment of building Trump Tower
and there he benefited from his father
being having as his best friend the
mayor of New York who or issued orders
whatever mr. Trump wants he's going to
get and the bureaucracy turned to his
side even the Wollman Rink Donald told
people it was a pro bono project and he
got him to work for free now he got ten
million dollars for it so it means it is
literally all a fraud his life so I'm
sorry if I had won I would tell you all
right
well listen thank you all very much
and books on royalty of duplicating the
middle class this classic flows have
been Republicans bullying NATO I think
both I think white America